oh he's pushing in
he's pushing him and people are on the
ground
he's pushing him it's petrol crisis time
and the day has come that i finally need
some petrol in my car so i am going to
go and try and find some
now i'm on a bit less than a quarter of
a tank definitely less than quarter of a
tank close to kind of dangerously low on
petrol first thing we're doing by the
way as a little aside is picking up some
jerry cans for
from my friend who is pregnant and has
run out of petrol hello hello you guys
have cherry
yes they wrap everywhere thank you very
much guys let's see thank you this is
the kind of stuff that's going to get
you beaten up at a petrol station
they're going to be like red rags to
bulls
for the past couple of days because i've
been seeing this nonsense um of what's
been going on at the pumps i've actually
been rationing my journeys in the car
social media has really fed this crisis
so there is a petrol station ahead of me
this is petrol station number one
and look at that
sorry no fuel
turn around so you haven't been able to
work for delivering uber uh uber food
yeah you're delivering and you've been
unable to work from thursday because
there's been no petrol
every year
the field was finished was that clear
that he's an uber driver
god that's awful so this is petrol
station number two
and it looks like there is absolutely
nothing here but this is pretty dire now
actually it's like
it's mad the police
are you guys looking for petrol
oh
do you have your own supplies somewhere
okay
do you know of any places where there
might be petrol
oh really that was a policeman who's
just told me that the bp petrol station
that's about 10 minutes drive from here
had a delivery this morning but
apparently it was mental that is where
we're gonna go now
in order to give it a go
oh my god look it's rammed but it's
because they've got petrol it must be
let's do it
so this is petrol station number three
and look at the queue i've missed two
days of work already monday and tuesday
i'm just trying to work for tomorrow
because i know there's people here
that's filling up their fuel plus a
jerry can or two it's actually crazy the
amount of people is panicking
and there's no shortage of fuel i don't
think there's any shortage there will be
now this is basically blocking off
traffic that access to this petrol
station is blocking off traffic for
people actually getting around the
roundabout you do not skip a q in in
britain
[Music]
i tell you if this is russia or france
people have been quite patient really
i'm desperate to go and give flu jobs
and i'm worried that if i'm so late my
customers will just go and wait the
police know that there is fuel here why
not please sit yeah i know the policeman
was like oh it's mental
good luck
it looks like we may actually be able to
get petrol here
if it doesn't run out right in front of
our noses
can you tell me what's it been like for
the past four days
we don't we yesterday unfortunately
anger is cancelled but a lot of people
are waiting and going i i spoke to thank
you driver he said i don't have any
problems so i don't know uh four
carriages nothing i'm only going to put
thank you very much
i also have jerry cans which might get
me beaten up there's shaming going on
here
i'm gonna get so ashamed for the jerry
cans
so
yes it's finally happening
i can only fill up
30 pounds worth of petrol
um because that's the socially
responsible thing to do
you do feel like a wanker doing it don't
you
[Music]
does it know when it's like full
[ __ ] i'm making a real mess of this i
know i can't believe you you've never
done this before i've never done this
before okay done
done
slightly covered in petrol but done
i've been queuing up for about two hours
two hours yes so yeah very relieved i'll
tell you what though
there's no coppers around when you blame
on a copper just to sort out the
the cube the queue there
and
hooted and the fights and the arguments
there's no one around so that was
exciting i got into a bit of a flat
because
i feel
like
i thought i'd be attacked for filling up
the jerry cans because that's like the
you know
the image of a selfish wanker is someone
who's stockpiling petrol um whereas i
was just getting it for a friend we're
now about to pay for it probably an hour
and a half after we started uh yeah i
mean there's a sweet sense of relief
pleasant
and
a little bit of emptiness as well
you